Yes, this is a dream come true,
and she wrote and directed
and stars in a personal new project, "Life & Beth,"
a show about revisiting your past
to understand your present.
And there's a very special actress
in "Life & Beth" who plays the younger version of you.
I'm gonna show a clip so we can introduce her.
(gentle music)
You want to try some?
Okay.
All right, come here.
Open your mouth like this.
Ah.
Yeah, a little more.
Good job.
'Kay, a little more.
Ah.
Okay.
Now look.
No, I just fixed it.
What's wrong with you?
(audience applauds)
Oh, that's so well-shot.
Ugh, God, that moment's so poetic and beautiful.
I could cry.
Oh, it's so haunting.
I'm just like, set.
Okay, she's here.
Please welcome Violet Young.
(audience applauding)
Hi, Violet.
Hey, guys.
Thanks so much for having us.
Violet, may I ask, like, what was Amy's approach?
Like, what advice did she give you
about playing her younger self?
Yeah, I mean, I think I just tried
to learn as much about young Beth from Amy,
and I got so much wonderful guidance.
You know, obviously, dynamics with family and friends,
and just kind of growing up as a as a teenager in,
you know, middle school to high school.
Yeah, I got some really great advice,
so I'm excited for everyone to see young Beth, and yeah.
And Amy, when you met Violet,
what was it that you identified in her?
There was, you know,
no offense to anyone else who auditioned,
but there was just no one else.
She just came, it was like,
you know if you watch "American Idol" or something
and people come in,
and then somebody opens their mouth,
and you're just like, okay, we have a star, you know?
It was totally like that.
Okay, as a last question, Violet,
why should everybody watch "Life & Beth"?
I think everyone should watch "Life & Beth"
because I think you'll laugh and you'll cry
and your mascara will drip
all over your face in the best way.
So, I think it's a really beautiful stew.
It's a bit of everything,
and I'm excited for everyone to see it.
I absolutely love that.
(audience cheering)
Wow.
Amy and Violet.
"Life & Beth" is available on Hulu now.
I celebrate you both, I celebrate the show,
and thank you both so much for being here.
(upbeat music)